I'm duve this is my dog Jedi and today
we worked on the set of
[Music]
xmiss go pick it up bring it bring bring
bring bring come on hurry bring bring it
was actually a pretty difficult retrieve
where Jedi had to retrieve some awkward
objects we had to train him to bring it
and drop it in a hole and not just bring
something to me or to another actor so
that was another kind of level of
training I thought he did a great job
considering the uh strange items he had
to rri today the variety of uh Jesus
dolls we've got rubber duck Jesus baby
Jesus and um the T-Rex Jesus which is my
personal favorite he's got a big
presence and a big personality H and he
just loves to have fun all the time but
I'm very entertained and I'm really
looking forward to this movie coming
[Music]
out